what are people talking about when they
refer to the unconscious
mind a lot of times people are talking
about a mystery that they kind of know
is within them because it gets talked
about but they're not sure how much of
an influence does that have over me like
is that me but I'm not aware do I know
who I am consciously but then there's
other things in the background and and I
think often it can be confusing and even
scary if we don't understand what does
that mean how does it have control over
us if we think like us is the conscious
part of us and how can we have control
over it yeah it's strange to think what
does it mean that there's a part of me
I'm basically entirely unaware of that
somehow influences me in ways that I can
become aware of right right right and
that's why the sort of height of of
understanding ourselves through the the
the lens of understanding all aspects of
the Mind including the unconscious mind
includes an awareness of some of what's
going on there but also an awareness
that we're not aware of it
all yeah it's a little bit of a paradox
why why is it so important is there an
analogy is it is it like the surface web
and the dark web is it 99% of ourselves
are unconscious and only 1% of us is
conscious well far more of us is
unconscious than conscious
far far more of us the the iceberg model
where the our conscious mind is a little
part of the iceberg that's above the
water but the vast majority of it is
underwater we need that in order to be
able to move through time you know just
like say a car engine might be you know
rotating several thousand uh revolutions
per minute right we're not aware of all
those revolutions but that needs to
happen for us to seamlessly be able to
maneuver the car forward right so in a
far more complicated way that's going on
on inside of us where there are
thousands upon thousands upon thousands
of of calculations that are going on so
that we can sum things and come up to
the Consciousness where we can then make
conscious decisions so so even the idea
of say walking down the street and
seeing someone walking towards you right
there's so much that then goes on what
does that person look like does that
person is a person looking at you or
they looking down if they looking at you
do they look happy they look not happy
do you recognize them do you not
recognize them are there mark of threat
are they not markers of threat you you
know we're doing all sorts of things and
let's say that person looks like someone
who had been aggressive before but is
not that person then we're triggered to
like have this an extra sense of anxiety
and tension that all that happens
automatically then we have to say Okay
that's but it's not a person who's been
aggressive before but it all goes on in
us in a way of kind of bringing us up to
speed with that moment so that we can
make whatever conscious decision we're
making so the conscious decision could
be walk to the other side of the street
or say hello or look down you say oh
you're just doing one thing you're only
you're doing one thing because it's
riding a top thousands upon thousands of
things that let you in in the conscious
world so to speak do the one thing that
there that choice that there is to make
there's obviously lots of other
unconscious things that go on the
impetus to breathe in and breathe out
the impetus for our body to digest the
food and for our heart to pump and all
the rest of the things but presumably
there are certain things that are more
Salient to our day-to-day experience
especially uh phenomenologically what it
feels like to be a person in the world
with thoughts there are areas I I don't
often think about my digestion unless
I've got something wrong but I do think
about that person or that situation
that's kind of similar to one that's
from before and made me feel a little
bit like I might not be liked by people
and what does that mean for me now and
there's yeah there's like a triage there
a a priority list of things that are
Salient to you right the the key word
there is salience right because in fact
we could put two s's here it's safety
and salience so so our our brains want
to Keep Us Alive right so we we want to
be safe and and what is Salient will be
determined by that like if we're safe we
can think about other things we can read
a book we can relax we can do we can
have a podcast we can do whatever we
choose to do when we're safe but safety
has to come first so as you said you're
not spending a lot of time thinking
about your GI system but it let's say
you we hope there isn't but let's say
there's some problem and now it's going
to tell you that right you're going to
have pain and the pain is going to make
your GI system Salient then you think
about it but if there's not a a risk
that's coming from it it it stays in the
background so so first and foremost our
brains want to keep us safe which is why
the the triggering of negative events of
trauma become so Salient so the example
I I often give is you imagine in we're
hunter gatherers and and if we're hungry
and we we go out and we find a new berry
to eat right if that's tastes good and
it's nourishing it's really good to
remember that let's say it makes us very
very sick then we better remember that
right we have to remember that so there
there's more salience to negative things
things that are charged with negative
emotion because those are more commonly
about safety which is why if you see
someone who looks like someone you've
had conflict before it triggers all
sorts of reactions in US same thing if a
person has been in a car accident then
gets in a car right I talked to someone
this morning who had a a very difficult
event happened 24 years ago and and was
saying but when he's in that similar
situation which in the course of his
work he is on a daily basis he feels as
if it was a moment ago because it was
very very distressing it's immed
immediate to this person even after 20s
something years because it was about
safety at the time and the brain w does
not want to let that go it wants
reassurances that we're safe before it
lets those things go that's why trauma
and traumatic stimuli are so Salient in
us and so dominant in the unconscious
mind because first and foremost it wants
to keep us moving from this moment to
the next moment which means we got to
make it to the next moment so we have to
stay safe I was in a head-on collision
when I was 20 years old 20 or 21 years
old at 60 MPH with a snowplow on the
main British Motorway in the UK and for
the next probably 6 weeks or so after
that maybe maybe even more maybe like
two months to three months or so uh
every time that I was close to Contra
flow traffic so traffic coming in the
other direction on the side of the road
near the side of the road that I was
where there wasn't a barrier between us
I felt anxious and it's like I guess
it's like stubbing your toe you don't
realize how often things touch your toe
until there is a highper sensitivity
around it I didn't realize how often I
was you know 5T away from another
vehicle coming basically head on toward
me until I'd been hit by a snow plow at
60 miles an hour right right then your
brain of all the things that could be a
risk to you but your brain says that is
a risk to me oncoming traffic is a risk
to me and then it becomes very very
sensitive ized to it and if you're
having intrusive thoughts and a high
level of vigilance know that's when it
can become problematic you said for some
period of time right a few months then
it it sort of settles back down in you
but the that makes sense right and it
may be that you change behaviors or you
don't change behaviors you know it's say
I don't want to be on you know roads
with FASTT traveling traffic you know
you might change behaviors due to that
but your brain is bringing it to the
Forefront because in some ways it's
saying is this okay is this does this
really make sense to do now even if you
decide it does make sense to do even
though something bad has happened your
brain is going to persist in ways
because the the trauma has such a deep
emotional resonance our our memories
don't have meaning in and of themselves
they're brought to life by the emotion
that's attached to them so if we had
asked you a week before um person going
one way in traffic and a vehicle coming
the other way hits them like okay that
doesn't sound great but it but it's not
going to raise a lot of emotion in you
let's say we asked you one week later it
will raise a huge amount of emotion
because now your brain says of all those
risks to me that is one that is Salient
and then it'll want to sort out should
you change behaviors but sometimes even
after that goes away that that question
and you've made an answer to it it can
Linger on in the brain and deping on the
person and the situation and the
specifics for years and years and years
with the rest rest of a person's life
which if you think from the perspective
of safety and salience we can understand
why but but also that's not the way we
want to be living life if we understand
safety salience the unconscious mind how
our minds work then we can change that
and say I don't want that thing to carry
along with me just because something bad
happened I I understand what happened I
I'm making decisions about it I don't
need my brain to continue to shove that
to the Forefront it seems like the
important thing here is bringing the
unconscious I into the
conscious how do you how do you do that
what does that
mean well often times there are other
ways we can come at it too you know
sometimes there's specific tactics
around decreasing symptomatology so
there are other ways of coming at
symptoms we may have on the mental
health front right including symptoms
after trauma but a big part of what
we're doing is what you're saying is to
be aware of what is in the unconscious
mind and to be able to bring it to
consciousness so a lot of times if the
brain is saying you are not safe if
you're in a car going at un coming at
oncoming traffic you are not safe you
are not safe you are not safe it's going
to say that over and over unless you can
validate hey let's bring that to
Consciousness and say I understand why I
feel that way I understand why that is
that is in me and I am aware of it and
then that enables a set of processes
some of them can occur through therapy
some don't have to though where get your
mind around it so to speak and then your
brain doesn't have to continue to push
it to the Forefront I mean that that's
what trauma therapy is doing in in some
sense but it doesn't often require
therapy sometimes it does but bringing
the unconscious to conscious to the
conscious mind lets us have much greater
control over it including often
validating hey I know why that's in me
like thank you in a sense brain but I
don't need it at the Forefront and it's
remarkable how much like that works I
mean it's it's part of what trauma
therapy is and it can take symptoms and
decrease them through Insight what do
you wish more people knew about
trauma I wish that more people knew that
it comes so frequently to so many of us
and that it is Insidious and the meaning
of that word like something that is
sneaky and like a a wolf and sheep's
clothing like it doesn't announce itself
that I'm now in your brain and changing
you and including changing your memories
so and I don't know what happened to you
a after and and again I'm sorry to learn
about what happened but an example would
be on the other side of that a person
who's gone through what you've gone
through could conclude I never feel safe
in a car I've never felt safe in a car I
don't like driving I don't feel could
conclude that without it being
true oh so they've retroactively gone
back and changed their memory of sit
situations prior to that trauma as a
compensatory mechanism as a story they
tell themselves well it's it's a way
because the the brain is going to paint
with a broad brush if we're not bringing
the trauma to conscious understanding
then it's saying it's a very simple
conclusion right being in car coming at
opposite traffic is not safe right and
that's all the brain knows like we got
hurt doing that so we can't do that
anymore so it'll bring that to you and
the emotion is so strong that it can
color the old memory saying but you
never want to be in a car anyway right
you never felt comfortable in fact you
don't even want to travel places like it
can bring these things to the surface
it's remarkable how many people will say
I never had Faith or confidence in
myself I never thought I could do well
at my job I never thought I was smart
enough I never wanted to get out of my
hometown I never wanted to be in a
relationship people says but when you
talk to them that's not true I mean I'm
saying it's always not true but in many
many situations it's not true it's the
brain trying to keep them safe but
that's where the brain will like I'm
exagger ating a little bit like have you
hiding under the bed all day to keep you
safe right when that's not what we want
we want to be able to keep ourselves
safe so maybe if you were in the
accident when the road conditions were
poor that's why a snowplow was out you
might say look I don't want to be going
against oncoming traffic if its speed is
more than 30 kilometers per hour
whatever it may be in bad conditions
like maybe you learn that and you're
like I you know what I take that away
with me and I'm going to change that you
might conclude that or you might
conclude not that but you're concluding
something that tells your brain it
doesn't have to be lost in that trauma
now for you it sounds like it went down
after some period of time but for some
people it doesn't until it's processed
like again person I saw earlier today
20s something years ago it is still with
the person as if it were yesterday and I
see this many days not just that I
happen to see that today it's like I see
that a lot which is why I had a
conversation about it just this morning
so Insidious more frequent
than people think more persistent than
people think and changeable and and uh
not uh locked set in stone for the rest
of your life it's not hardwired in us uh
it we don't have to be afraid of it
because trauma triggers a reflex of
guilt and
shame so if we are traumatized there is
some reflex and and I don't know if you
had that after your trauma people so I
shouldn't have been where I was when
someone attacked me or when there was an
accident now sometimes we may have some
bear some responsibility but that's
different than a reflex of guilt and
shame which tells you shove the trauma
down below don't look at it if you look
at it oh Lord knows what you will find
if you look at it what's the function of
the shame and the
guilt so the the function is probably
around behavior modification again it's
all theoretical right but if you think
about psychological history of humans
and even an anthropological psychology
like how humans develop that we have
what are called affects and I don't want
to get too off into the weeds but
neurobiologically there's a difference
between affects feelings and emotions
and affects are just aroused in us like
if you're just walking down the street
and someone jumps in front of you and
shoves you you're going to feel anger or
fear or boast before you know it think
about that you're going to feel anger or
fear or but it'll be coursing inside of
you and then you be become aware why
because affects are create they create
change in us if someone just jumps in
front of you and shoves you or yells at
you you better be ready to fight to flee
right you boot up all these systems and
then you're aware so these very deep
affects in us very primary fear love joy
shame they they they anger they they're
created in Us in order to protect us so
shame is very very powerful for altering
Behavior so imagine if you're in small
groups of people and you know you've got
the food inside the cave and you close
the cave door and then somebody wakes up
in the middle of the night and eats a
bunch of the food the rest of the people
may make that person feel ashamed right
or they you know they're they're keeping
they're doing something that makes the
supply at risk you know whether people
are are relieving themselves is too near
the food like it then shame is a
mechanism of change don't do that any
don't do that again it puts you at risk
it puts others at risk so it has a very
strong impact upon us but it gets
harnessed in ways that are not about
survival like we're not living in a
hunter gatherer Society where if you and
I go faring for berries and we almost
die we better never forget it right like
it's different from that we live longer
lives right that are much more diverse
and can be impacted by shame in ways
that can have a person who was attacked
by someone else decades ago with no
fault of their own still feeling guilty
that they were attacked ashamed that
they were attacked and deeply altering
their behaviors because of that that's
Survival mechanisms hijacked in a way
that shuts down people's lives and
Trauma does not have to have this kind
of control over us but in doing what I
do for a living I've seen whoa the
greatest external control mechanism upon
us is the one we don't see that alters
even our memory so we don't even
recollect accurately wow that's so
interesting and it it's so crazy to
think that scenarios we go through
become interpreted by ourselves and
woven into a story that we tell
ourselves about who we've always been
right then the incident that was the
Genesis of that is not forgotten but it
being the Genesis of it is forgotten
right and it just becomes a part of us
and then people will begin to identify
with that oh that's me that's how I've
always been I've always been an X or a y
or a zed person and if you we all know
how much people try to defend their egos
and their personalities if you tried to
say well you know why don't we go away
on holiday you know I don't like going
away on holiday I've never liked going
away on holiday no you had a very
turbulent flight when you were 7 years
old or 13 years old or 25 years old and
this Landing came in and you told
yourself a story that you no longer want
to go on what I'm fascin ated by not
only that not only the fact
that instances formative instances can
change the story tell ourselves about
ourselves and then make us forget the
fact that that is what caused it to
happen but that shame and guilt are
almost like the delivery mechanism for
enforcing the change and it doesn't need
to come from other people you know
you're right that you do a thing and
guilt is the uh internal version of the
external eye that your tribe would have
had on you saying you probably shouldn't
be doing you shouldn't be eating those
berries oh God I hope no one catches me
but you're deploying this to yourself
about yourself and maybe about something
that wasn't even your fault yes it's
something yes it's all of that so you're
really getting it's all of that and it's
even worse because that shame and guilt
all the things you just said are like
centuries protecting us from Insight
protecting us from help that say it's
not safe to go look at that it's not
safe to talk about that you want to go
talk about something you're ashamed
about that that's not going to go well
right it has us keep it all inside
because guilt and shame keep us stuck
inside of ourselves which is the reason
why people don't don't go and get help
they don't go in process because guilt
and shame tells us to keep it private
and it tells us well people say all the
time I'll start crying and never stop
I'll curl up into a fetal position and
never get out that is never what happens
those are the lies
of trauma driven guilt and shame that
keep us in places where we not only
don't know who we are but we forget who
we are how many times I've had a person
tell me I've always been someone no one
likes no one was and I learned like
that's not that's not true at all people
this person understood themselves to be
different and and interacted in the
world differently until that trauma
happened because the thing you said
about the airplane flight could happen
when someone is seven happen when
they're 57 too right and then we go back
and we map the past which English
interestingly um English modernism
really really captured this so so it's
not only this wasn't known before but
the English modernist like Ford madx
Ford Virginia Wolf's writing really
there were others too that started
writing about how we retroactively
change I think it was Ford madx Ford who
wrote about if you're eating an apple
and it's a goodly apple I think he wrote
and you get to the center of it and
there's a worm is it retroactively a bad
apple right and and that that was quite
a revelation that was part of the
English modern
movement that that that really realized
and I in my opinion I think Virginia
wolf captured it the most deeply of of
how time uh changes for us in in the
context of how we see things in
retrospect how we see ourselves that the
the past is malleable and and it is our
our responsibility to ourselves that our
past isn't malleable if something
changed in me after a trauma I want to
know how I was before what that trauma
was how it impacted me how it changed me
how I am different afterwards so that I
can decide what that means and how I'm
going to go about doing about it
whatever it is I choose to do are
different categories of trauma do you do
you bucket them into broad types somehow
well on the one hand this is where I
emphasize here that this is based in
science right this is not um some soft
concept of oh anybody who has trauma or
anything bad not chosen for the team or
no no the answer to your question can be
answered through the lens of hard
science but in two ways on the one hand
the answer is no in that if my brain
changes because of let's say vicariously
experienced trauma through sitting with
other people through their trauma or
being present for something and your
brain changes because of some acute
trauma that happened to you our brains
look the same afterwards the patterns of
neurotransmission change we're both more
Vigilant we will both tend to have
different patterns like if you see a new
face coming at you instead of being
looking at it objectively I wonder who
that is or what what that person's
expression is or feelings we look at it
biased is that person going to harm me
right we change and we change in the
same way so in one sense no because the
brain changes are the same and and
physical data like heart disease risk
for example can be higher and when
trauma is really manifesting itself
aging can be greater so so think about
this because of the impact of trauma we
can be older than we are where the
calendar says that person is 42 years
old but if you go and you kind of think
about tiir and how the person is
actually 46 by the by the actual biology
of it so the hard brain biology and and
physical biology tells us that the final
common pathway is the same but we can
get traumatized in different ways the
easiest way to see is acute right you
told me about a head-on collision like
whoa I mean anyone can understand yeah
that will traumatize a person you know
I've as I've written about and talked
about in podcasts I lost my youngest
brother by Suicide everyone can
understand like that's a big trauma
we're less likely to understand chronic
traumas so chronically be being um made
to feel less that so people who are
chronically denigrated whether it's it's
ethnicity it's sexual preference or
identity like there are many many things
that that we in society socioeconomic
status lead people to feel chronically
less than so there's research showing
when immigrant groups when people
immigrate to a country with very
different traditions and they tend to
live together there's a lower uh
incidence of schizophrenia so people
live apart there's a higher incidence
this is fascinating right because when
people are living together there's more
of a sense of belonging right we don't
know this for sure but the data points
that way and it fits with this idea that
we see like we see it to be true that
chronic trauma is impactful so someone
who's in an an abusive circumstance and
nothing has risen to some drama where
they went to the hospital or police came
but it's always they're always
denigrated that will make brain changes
just like acute trauma so acute chronic
and vicarious trauma where which why I
often am telling people my prescription
for you is less News Right Use the news
to inform yourself right use use the
news to learn when I was young there was
a newspaper that came you look through
it that was it now people are often
they're looking at news so to speak but
what they're doing is experiencing by
cariously other people's trauma and we
need to be very careful about that it
happens in the helping professions it
happens if someone's near someone who's
been hurt and it happens if we're
constantly inundating ourselves because
of our own anxiety with other people's
suffering I read a study from the Boston
Marathon bombing which was a few years
ago and they looked at
people who had actually been at the
marathon during the bombing and compared
their levels of stress to people who had
watched 90 minutes or more of news
coverage about it the people who watched
90 minutes or more of news coverage on
average showed higher levels of stress
yes that does not surprise me that that
fits with all the other data which say
if you're there yes something very bad
has happened and you're in proximity to
it but we're talking about people who
then
weren't hurt in it right or didn't have
someone close to them who was hurt then
you realize that there is safety right
now that doesn't mean it's not going to
have an impact on the person to realized
that happened and I was close to it but
should it surprise us that if n in 90
minutes of oh my goodness you know that
could have been me or someone I love and
you know just imagining that and feeling
for the people gu we are so fortunate as
humans we have empathy if we didn't we
wouldn't be here right we're lucky in
some ways we're here anyway with how
close we come to destroying ourselves
even with empathy so empathy is
wonderful if someone is hurt and they're
on on the ground that's why we lend them
helping hand metaphorically and and
truly empathy is great but empathy can
work against us that's why we see people
who have a full blown trauma syndrome
and it's all through vicarious trauma
and that is real because the brain
science will show it to be just as real
as someone who's had the trauma in a
more acute and obvious way I'm going to
guess that
chronic and vicarious trauma are the
ones that sneak up on people you know
when we think about trauma we think
about a single formative uh fireworks
event that goes on
we you know if you were to say well
you've been in a relationship where your
partner has always put you down for a
decade you would say well are any of
those instances by you know the lay
person definition of trauma are any of
those instances traumatic well no like
it's just a joke they're just saying
like oh like you know oh going out for a
run good luck trying to get past one
kilometer again this time you know but
over time there is a point there is a
point in which something which is not
necessarily traumatic in isolation
becomes traumatic just due to like
weight sure sure right the area under
the curve right the increasing weight of
the The Chronic denigration you can see
how in our Medical Systems and I've been
fortunate to spend about a year of my
life in the UK and I I love coming uh to
to England but I think I understand the
Health Care System enough that there
there are problems in the US Health Care
system that are that are in other
systems too right which is just being
too concrete about about things where
it's it's hard to get attention and Care
especially human driven attention like
psycho therapy right so so our system
wants to look at hey have you had the
big fireworks event okay if not we'll
put you in a different in a different
category it doesn't want to say are
there changes in your brain because of
trauma whether that was acute or chronic
or vicarious that's what we would look
at but that the systems aren't
sophisticated or or often interested
enough to do that I went to my GP when I
was probably 21 or 22 in the UK
Northeast of the UK classic very working
class town and I go in and I sit down
and I'd been sad for quite a while on
and off and then every so often there
would be maybe a couple of days where I
couldn't get out of bed and I would feel
quite ashamed about this and I wouldn't
want to talk to people and I'd keep the
curtains drawn and you know I'd make
excuses about why I couldn't see people
or do things or whatever and uh I went
in and I sat down with my GP and the way
it works in the UK for the people that
aren't from there you have a 10-minute
window with your GP and that's your
general practitioner that's the person
you go to and you book in for and it's
usually kind of hard to get an
appointment again National Health
Service it's free great but the standard
of care perhaps leaves a little bit be
desired so I sit down and I said I'm uh
I'm I I think I might be depressed or
something I probably mumbled some word
out about sad or depressed or something
like that but I'm pretty sure I used the
word depression and this GP said uh have
you had a recent family B bereavement no
says are you in financial trouble no did
you recently lose a job no did you
recently break up with a relationship no
no no no no no all the way down like
acute trauma acute trauma acute trauma
acute trauma no and sort of got toward
the end of it and essentially said well
what are you sad about I was I don't
know like just the [__] crushing
weight of existence I don't know I don't
know what I'm sad about and then she
printed off this single piece of A4
paper that was like oh here's some
website URLs on the NHS website about
how to improve your mental health like
and go along your way and you left worse
than when you came in I I I felt like I
don't know like I was making a mountain
out of a mole hill uh it definitely
taught me the lesson that I took away
from that I think was um I'm blowing
this out of proportion I mustn't it
mustn't be that big of a deal and that's
why we have so much to loss of
productivity because often people in in
power uh in decision-making capacities
think about dollars and cents or pounds
and and are we what are we losing
economically we lose a tremendous amount
of human productivity because of
depression and if we want to Anchor to
what is of course infinitely more
important we lose human life to
depression so when you walk out of there
you're walking out at Great risk you
have a real medical problem if you went
in and you had right lower quadrant
abdominal pain that had been Amorphis
and then and then all of a sudden it
started being focused here no one would
say why do you have a pentis why does
your abdomen hurt no one would say that
right they would honor what was going on
with you but here you get a a a a
non-response and you leave worse than
you came in because it's so invalidating
and no one is then looking at hey if we
could take a picture of your brain
chemistry we're not sophisticated enough
to just do that we'd see yeah you have a
medical problem no different than if you
had a pend thetis but you walk out and
validate it and this is the problem and
it's part of why at some point realizing
that most of what I was treating was
coming from trauma whether I was
treating treating substance abuse
depression panic attacks insomnia right
even the the the more medicalized like
schizophrenia higher incidents when
people are are feeling a a a sense of
aloneness and isolation and
vulnerability that we need to understand
this because a huge part of what ails us
what makes all of us suffer is coming
from this it's coming from unrecognized
and unaddressed Trauma and unrecognized
and unaddressed mental health issues
because look people can get depressed
because their brain chemistry is off
right so there doesn't have there could
be no reason whatsoever the people
everything in their life is as good as
possible but cyclically their brain
chemistry comes offline and now they're
depressed so what about a purely
biological depression there isn't always
a reason I mean there's a lot of times a
reason but think about how we're just
invalidating people and then is it a
surprise that substance abuse substance
dependence addiction overdose rates go
up and up that suicide rates go up and
up it is not a surprise it is a
predictable outcome it's a predictable
consequence of how the Health Care
System handles it itself and and what
you described so many years ago is not
different in in many settings now so
that's what would happen now and and
even the doctor I have so much
compassion for GPS primary care
physicians because what are you supposed
to do in 10 minutes how you supp have a
real conversation in in 10 minutes and
that's why there's more depression and
self harm and suicides in Physicians has
grown over time that's an interesting
question what about you know you talked
about vicarious
trauma firefighters that need to cut
people out of cars paramedics that are
unable to resuscitate people therapists
that are dealing with uh masses that are
permanently working with people who are
in pain is this something that you see
sure there there are higher rates of all
that ails Us in in populations that are
exposed to to situations that can make
fear or Terror if you're coming up to
cut someone out of an accident is it's
it's hard to do that without some if
you're doing that you're a person who
has empathy so you're a person who's
going to feel something as you're doing
that and and sure people have Education
and Training and support to try and make
boundaries but that doesn't mean that
that works all the time we we don't give
people enough ongoing support and and
and we see that on the other side of it
where people in th these kinds of
helping professions have higher rates
was depression substance abuse suicide
the rates are higher and again it all
makes sense like there's this concept in
a certain um type of therapy that says
everything is as it should be it doesn't
mean that it's right morally right or or
just what it means is that it's
predictable it's predictable so if you
see the the increasing rates of
loneliness isolation depression
substance use suicides in in the general
population and more specifically in in
in people who are caregiving that's not
surprising since everything is as it
should be meaning we've made these
decisions as a society how many
healthcare workers came to the other
side of covid traumatized by all the
things that the awful things they saw
and they need to work double shifts
because the co-workers aren't coming in
they're so so much of that and what
happened after the pandemic go back to
the same unreasonably High work lows and
the way everything was before that we
don't we don't put resources in society
towards the people who help us which is
also us like you know we're all part of
this and you know we we we waste so many
resources in so many ways our political
struggles and strivings and it's the
idea isn't to get political but just to
say how much resources we waste and we
often don't have resources to like give
the person with depression more than a
10-minute misleading questionnaire right
or help that person who who has a real
post-trauma syndrome get better but
that's going to take some human time and
we look at the at the short end of it
which is why I focus on the economic
cost of course the human costs are more
but but we can get money allocated
sometimes resources allocated when we
look at the cost the for everyone we
don't treat for trauma who then uses
Hospital resources coming to emergency
rooms or we lose out of the workforce
it's you know it's like we would say
like a borrow a penny today to pay a
dollar tomorrow you know it it's but we
treat ourselves that way we treat
ourselves that way as societies and you
know people don't see it until they
often need to go to an emergency room
and they have good insurance but guess
what you're still out the hallway right
you still sat there for seven hours you
know you still went in and had somebody
ask you a 10-minute questionnaire when
you're really in trouble inside you know
maybe you know it's you know we don't
handle things in a way that uses a lot
of foresight and we pay for it and we
pay for it I believe around trauma more
than anything else I should say one more
quick fact that more than half we don't
know exactly how many but more than half
of the physical health complaints people
make they go to a physical health doctor
something hurts they have shortness of
breath they're feeling something inside
half of those complaints they're not
mental health complaints they're
physical health complaints that come
from mental health yet how much are we
integrating mental health into our
physical Health Care Systems very very
very poorly and and therefore you have
physical health Physicians who want to
help people they know so much that's
coming to them as mental health but
they're not equipped they're not trained
they don't have enough time and and
that's part of the frustration is people
are coming with mental health problems
but they're presenting as physical
health problems and it's it's not
because the person wants to say that
it's because they often don't know they
are hurting but they do have depress
they just don't know and the Health Care
system is so dumbed down that we're not
asking the right questions to try and
figure out what is actually going on
with you and how do we help you talk to
me about what actually happens to the
brain and body after someone's gone
through
trauma so there' be very complex changes
but we can sort of summarize to some
degree by saying that there are
alterations in the balances in our
brains you know our brains are trying to
maintain and bodies homeostasis means
things are in balance and there are
hundreds of thousands of things that
happen inside of us in each moment to
Hold Us in Bal in in Balance what
happens is that we get imbalanced so for
example vigilance mechanisms in the
brain their whole systems of the brain
salience mechanisms start looking more
for negative things so someone who for
example Le is interested in finding a
relationship who who is walking down the
street or a hallway and sees someone
look at them instead of being curious oh
how's that person looking at me or or
might I am I attract to that person
might I Smile Back the immediate is like
does that um the person's looking
negatively at me what's wrong with me
right why are they looking at me like
it's hard to make life move forward then
right there's a change towards vigilance
and vulnerability inside of us so you
don't see maybe that's a coworker we
could collaborate at on something maybe
that's a potential romantic partner
who's smiling at me people don't don't
see that because the brain is shifted
from Curiosity how is that person
looking at me to there must be something
wrong they're looking at me in a
negative way because there's something
negative about
me so those things change in Us in very
complicated ways but it changes the
whole climate so to speak within us and
then it changes endocrinologically so
then we have more stress hormones
flowing in us and stress hormones
predisposed to vast ular disease to
heart disease to Strokes to autoimmune
diseases to to aging faster than our
calendar age so to to G to gaining
weight when we don't want to gain weight
to not being able to lose weight when
we're working hard to lose weight so
then what happens we get change from
head to toe because these systems shift
and again we don't realize that you know
the person who says I'm I'm a loser
because I can't lose weight and I'm and
I'm trying how many times do I hear that
and then you see they're actually do
doing the right things they they have a
good diet they have exercise they're not
losing weight because there's so many
stress hormones in them that it triggers
all these don't lose weight systems in
us so it's just these are just examples
but you can see I hope from the examples
that what we're talking about is whole
life change from top to bottom again
it's not happening in everyone but this
is happening a lot in small medium or
big ways but any amount of it is
unacceptable and then we just don't know
it I've always been someone nobody likes
or no one I no one likes how I look
right and people said they'll say this
and they don't was before that trauma
that's not how they felt and that's why
they were they got better jobs they
would leave one job for another if it
was better they had good relationships
they didn't stand up they didn't stand
for denigration in a relationship that
kind of off-putting they didn't stand
for that now they do and they don't even
realize that they never did and like how
are we gonna get out of it right if we
think this is how I've always been when
that's not
true it seems like the story that we
tell ourselves about ourselves is so
important that it's such a huge part
this narrative that we weave together
yes yes yes I'm so interested in knowing
people's life narratives because I'm in
the business of trying to help people so
you have to understand what their
narrative is as I say no one no one
comes out of the womb thinking you know
abuse is okay for
me no one thinks that right so how do we
get to the point of thinking that even
being in a relationship as you said
there's not physical violence but it's
always denigrating oh sure you're going
to yeah that's going to go well for you
this time give it a try see what happen
why would people put up with that all
the time instead of saying hey I don't I
don't want this this is worse than not
having a relationship I'll not have a
relationship till I find one that's
better we we have to trace what is the
roots of that was there some trauma and
that person started feeling differently
does that come from early formative
years was that person seen is less than
or denigrated because of race because
say gender in the home right for just
one example because of sexual
orientation socioeconomic status in the
communities around us was that bred into
that person because that's not natural
either you get to feel that you're good
enough to have a safe life in which you
strive for good things and if a person
doesn't I want to understand where that
came from what just implicated
informative years or big trauma at once
we've got to understand it yeah I I
think so many people you know myself
uded the voice in our heads is so
regularly negative that it seems like
that's just the physics of brains that
the texture of mind not my mind the mind
yes the factory settings are yes
critical
self-deprecating uh fearful
Vigilant uh mocking you know risk averse
all of those things um are you you know
there is a negativity bias we are
concerned finite creatures infinite
surrounding you know this asymmetry
between things that can make us a little
bit more alive and make us a lot more
dead and how much worse those are but
are you saying that that's not the way
that we should be because that I think
to a lot of people maybe myself included
is like a rather wild claim that we
shouldn't our minds aren't built to just
be negative we're not built to be that
way and the salience of negative things
doesn't have to make us that way so in
the berry example like what does that
mean don't eat that Berry again it
doesn't mean be afraid of any food now
but be afraid of any berries be afraid
of being outdoors it doesn't mean that
it's the the negativity bias is meant to
protect us it's what happens inside of
us in complex situations because we live
lives that are complicated have
different phases and we're often not
aware of our life narratives it's it's
that negativity bias that can help us to
feel negative all the time but it
certainly is not
deterministic of that which is why in an
oversimplified example I'm simplifi if
you say hey realize you shouldn't eat
that Berry you're not a dummy for eating
that Berry it look like a good Berry you
don't have to feel like you're
incompetent and you're not worth
anything because you ate the be like
you're okay you came through it here's
the lesson don't eat that Berry again
and maybe be just more careful about
berries is that good okay it's good but
that's often not how it goes it's like I
don't I don't know how to pick what to
eat and you know and I you know I gave
someone to someone else that person got
sick to I'm a terrible you know this is
what we do to ourselves and it is not
our Natural State we're not built to be
like that but we end up like that
because we are trying to keep ourselves
safe in a difficult and complex world
and we accumulate more negativity bias
more negativity now I've got a voice in
my head telling me what's wrong with me
all the time and well you know I had
this voice in my head for a long long
long long time and through a lot of
psychotherapy I I've been able to to
move it out of my primary Consciousness
but there was a time when I thought that
shadow voice was normal you know if I
dropped something or oh so stupid or
what's wrong with you like I was I mean
that was a shadow to me inside of me and
I had to realize that's not normal I
said I didn't come out of the womb
metaphorically we don't have words but
you know what I mean like no one comes
out of the womb thinking that way it's
not
normal get our minds around it that does
not have to stay with us I'm not saying
I'm a paragon of mental health and I
still need my work and I do my work but
I'll tell you that oppressive miserable
Mir robbing depression you uh producing
voice is not in my head anymore because
I had to realize that is not natural I
do not want it there I want to
understand and get my arms around why
it's there and I want it to go just like
I never I always felt I could go out and
work hard and Achieve things I did not
feel like I was cursed I did not feel
like there was something wrong with me
or the place or people I came from but I
certainly did after my brother died by
Suicide what's wrong with me that I
didn't didn't see that what's wrong with
us that that would happen to us I would
never say that about someone else what's
wrong with you that a family member died
by Suicide but I would say it to me and
that's how we are like you know good
people don't want to denigrate someone
else but we'll say it to ourselves and
we'll take it inside and I started
realizing I was feeling so differently
about myself and wait I never felt like
this before and I had good people around
me enough to realize I started getting
myself some help but it shows if we
don't know our narratives and that this
negativity is not natural to be at the
Forefront it can become the new normal
and then we think it was the old normal
too wow how much can we change that
voice can we actually get rid of
negative Pathways I remember once
reading something about once neurons are
laid down there is no undoing them there
are only building up other neurons so is
it a case of layering better voices on
top of worse voices or can worst voices
actually go away entirely yeah worst
voices can go away entirely now again I
put a little asterisk and I'll explain
this is both very very complicated and
very very simple okay we don't this
complicated part is for the
neuroscientists that of how do neurons M
uh how does neurotransmission work and
how do complex systems work like there's
a there's a lot a lot lot there but
let's just go to the the simple part
anything that has been overlearned
doesn't go away overnight okay so here
here's the example I this example I use
all the time and I I I think it's it
captures it I think let's say you and I
randomly took a word we just picked a
word I look around like I the word
simply is staring at me from something
else on my Des let's say we random word
let's you and I say it together 500
times let's say we did that then this
evening my time your Tom tomorrow
morning it's going to be in your head or
in my head right let's say we say
instead of 500 times 5,000 times it'll
be in our brain several days later but
it can atrophy and go away in this case
it's just a a silly experiment but our
brains still won't let go of it if you
and I say that word a thousand times our
brain isn't gonna our brains aren't
going to say I know that was just a
silly experiment let's get rid of that
no it's going to keep the word coming
and the word it's going to keep it
coming that's what goes on with the
negative biases inside of ourselves you
keep you have a set a feeling State and
a and a set of words and selft talks
like I'm not good enough I suck I this
you keep doing that over and over again
it is not going away quickly but we live
in a society that wants rapid results
that often packages Psychotherapy as we
get 10 sessions of this and then it's
over all that stuff can get better
tremendously better but it takes time if
that's been in your head for three four
months to a moderate degree let's plot
out a several month course to getting it
out if it's been in your head for years
well we're going to have to work on it
over time but that doesn't mean nothing
good happens until we're years down the
road it means we start working on it now
and it starts getting better and that's
the Simplicity of it that example really
holds if we said that word a thousand
times and we didn't say it anymore it'll
fall out of our brains and the same is
true with the lies of trauma that we
tell ourselves now again if something
has been so impactful upon us it can
still come back people have had who have
had thoughts of hurting themselves or
hurt themselves at some point in time
who haven't for years could still have
something really bad go on and the
thought will come into their head if I
make a very big mistake I can still that
voice can come back in go you're an
idiot right so so but I recognize that
doesn't mean I'm back at square one it
just means if there's a strong stimulus
that reflex and come back but it's not
with me I just I push it back out like I
I I get it I made a mistake I don't need
this inside me let's have it back out so
sometimes it we can it can kind of Rush
us once or twice if it's been strongly
in us but the answer to your question
about change is a very strong yes all of
that can change and it's not rocket
science like Neuroscience is more
complicated at in rocket science so in
some sense it is that's why there are
countless brilliant people who spend
their careers in Psychiatry Neuroscience
psychology that's wonderful that that's
happening what you and I and everyone
listening needs to know is not that I
take comfort that people are doing that
what we need to know is this is
absolutely approachable and and we
understand it but the but the mechanisms
of helping around us don't help they
don't teach us how to understand it they
don't tell us that things take time but
there's an understanding driven by
science and experience of of the
profession that tells us the answers to
this and gives us a road map to how to
make it different it's so interesting
that you say uh a formative experience
particularly stressful experience can
cause something like this to to reemerge
so a while ago I was doing a very
important podcast episode high stakes
and I tend to fast before I do this
which is good it keeps me nice and alert
little bit of cortisol and adrenaline
running through the blood is is nice for
for mental focus but I overshot it and I
went hypo partway through the podcast
and as I'm watching this person talk in
front of me all that I can hear in my
own mind is blank there's nothing my
whole mind's gone blank and I'm like
well that's not good I'm supposed to be
here and I'm here
in and I'm thinking wow I've got nothing
to say and as soon as that happened the
first thought that came to my mind was
you're not supposed to be here you never
supposed to be here everyone's laughing
at you you're boring no one thinks that
you've got anything interesting to say
you're blowing it this was your
shot you're useless nobody likes you no
one's ever liked you and I thought like
where has that voice coming from because
I thought I'd got rid of that voice I
spent 1500 sessions of meditation like
five years of daily journaling all of
that stuff and I looked at me inwardly
as well as I could and tried to look at
that part of me I don't know where it
comes from something from my childhood
that I didn't like this very negative
very cutting very cynical voice and
during a period of super super super
high pressure yes yes it came back yes
yes which makes sense and this is the
danger what's the danger the danger is
is of a self-fulfilling prophecy right
because because when those thoughts are
going through your head as you said when
you try and tune in on the person again
you're hearing the you're not hearing
the words why because all you've done in
between is inre your to stress level so
then there's the danger of it coming off
the rails so to speak but because
because you could inadvertently kind of
make that true at least in the moment
where like if that goes too far you
don't have something to say back right
and then it then when that happens to a
person now it really tells them oh this
is back with you this is all true that
can be very
very difficult for a person if they have
a bad outcome when things are back in
their mind what we want to do if you and
I let's say we're working together
clinically and I knew the strength of
that in your past I would try and
prepare you that hey let's just be clear
that's going to come back to you at some
point in time and it doesn't mean
anything you know the best thing you can
do and it comes back please you know
just laugh at it a little bit a little
bit of like that kind of like good humor
like I get it I get it when that that
when that you're an idiot comes back
into my head or you're stupid you're not
good enough to be here what made you
think go to medical school like I get
that I'm like look this is a this is
coming from the past right and then it
takes the power out of it then if you
can do that then you can go back and now
you're going to hear the words the
person is saying right but you have to
be prepared for it if you don't know
that that's normal for it to come back
then you can't just you know do that
what you do is you give it you
inadvertently give it so much power oh
my goodness it's back now I really can't
pay attention oh my gosh it must be true
I knew all of that meditation was a
waste I knew that the journaling wasn't
there this isn't the true me that was
the true me Etc right that's what I talk
about dismissive humor is our friend in
situations and I will prepare people for
that because it's inevitable if you had
these voices in your head if you've
worked very very hard to get them out of
your head that's the victory the victory
isn't they never ever encroach back in
that's just not how it works but it's
okay that they encroach back in if you
say I know what that message is and I
reject it let me stop and ground myself
I'm not at my best I overshot The Mark
with not eating before whatever like
I'll learn from that okay I'm here for a
reason I A lot of times I I um work with
athletes who are at the highest level of
performance of whatever they do and you
see them in a slump like I don't deserve
to be here as if like they should be on
the sand lot instead of in the major
league stadiums like you didn't
accidentally get to the stadium right
but even in a slump the person can tell
themselves they're no better than
someone who doesn't even know how to
play the sport like it shows what our
brains can do to us and and how
dramatically we can lose our
confidence what about trauma being
passed down is that a thing I'm living I
I live in uh Austin Texas now so
ancestral trauma is kind of a bit of a a
super meme over here with the
Psychedelic trips and the iasa Retreats
and the indigenous cultures and stuff
like that what's the what's the the the
truth in the BS around uh epigenetics
ancestral trauma all of that stuff it's
it's remarkable what epigenetics has
contributed um is is just immense to our
understanding the thought was for a long
time that trauma is passed down by role
modeling so someone say who has been
through trauma and is very anxious
communicates that to children that the
world is an unsafe place and they role
model anxiety and that can happen we we
can nurture children to be like us in
all sorts of ways right so that's why if
I have a lot of anxiety in me I I do my
best have control over that I don't want
to role model that for my
children but but what we've learned is
really really quite remarkable there are
epigenetic changes in Us in people that
then can be passed down to children who
aren't even conceived of yet and that's
where Darren richer re i c h ER t r Dr
Darren Richard who I interviewed for the
book is a is a a trauma expert he's an
academic at Sanford and he testifies
about trauma and this idea so for
example in the world court that that if
someone is traumatized for example some
of his test testimony has been around
rape as an instrument of of war and it
was seen through a criminal justice lens
this person ordered that and that was
wrong okay that's true but we also need
to look at that can extend across years
and across
Generations that could impact children
that aren't even thought of yet and
might not be born until 10 20 years
later because the trauma in the person
creates change in the person that can
then be transmitted to children just
through the changes in genetic
expression years and years and years
later and and that shift from looking at
like a war crime as something criminal
that's just that's bounded by it
happened in this period of time is is it
is a crime but it's it's not only a
crime in that moment it's a crime
against that person for the rest of
their lives especially if they they
don't get the help to deal with it and
it can be a it's a crime against
children that aren't even thought of yet
it's a it's a transgenerational crime
and that truth that epigenetics and and
epigenetics through the neurobiological
lens tells us that's true I was talking
to Robert spolski a couple of months ago
and he was talking about how mothers
that enter poverty during um uh
pregnancy the changes that you see
epigenetically in the children from that
poverty you know perfect example I would
guess of a a pretty good chronic trauma
chronic stressor it's not it's just
ambient concern right it's just there in
the background and uh yeah the the
difference that that people go through
and he reminded me something that I
learned in year nine in biology that
when a female is
born they have all of the eggs that they
are going to have for the entirety of
their life mhm yes so inside of this as
yet unborn child this infant baby fetus
that's inside of you is the next
Generation so right you've got
grandmother to mother that's about to be
born and inside of mother you have
daughter who is about you will be born
in however many 25 30 40 years time yes
yes right and you're wow that that
warrants it warrants that kind of wow
this is the impact of trauma truly
transgenerational and think about the
example you gave was not someone who has
lived chronically in poverty people can
live in poverty without poverty itself
being traumatic it predisposes to trauma
but poverty doesn't have to be in and of
itself traumatic but imagine you said a
woman entering poverty while pregnant I
mean even that if I if I stop and think
about that too much I could I can
generate a panic attack in myself of how
that would feel you're carrying a child
and you feel respons and now you go from
not being in poverty to being in poverty
what is the Cascade of stress hormones
neurobiologically and cascading
throughout the body it's it's huge and
that's why it makes the the significant
changes that Dr spolski is talking about
it's a huge trauma during a period of
time that is a very very crucial period
of time to that developing fetus which
is crucial to the developing fetus to
the adult that fetus will become and and
if that fetus can have children to the
subsequent children of that fetus if
this isn't a reason for us paying
attention it's not like borrow a penny
today pay back a pound tomorrow but are
we going to borrow Penny today and pay
back 10 pounds tomorrow and what 100
pounds in 10 years and a th000 pounds
down the road I believe that that is not
an exaggeration that is what we are
doing as a society by turning away from
trauma and we see it in death rates
through overdose and death death rates
through suicide there there are many
many things we could talk about where we
see that right now and what we see now
will continue on and worsen it's a
guarantee it will continue forward and
worsen because we've planted the seeds
of that into the future unless we do
something about it so we've talked about
the impact of trauma and unwinding of
that trying to make the unconscious into
the conscious what about trying to get
out ahead of that a little bit more are
there
any predictors or ways that people can
increase their resilience so that the
bar for whatever could cause a a
traumatic interpretation sort of bounces
off during the event what what's the the
physics of that system oh it's it's the
same Paradigm as for physical health
right the better health you're in the
better you'll be able to withstand an
insult to your physical health an injury
and illness and the same is true in our
mental health so the healthier we are if
someone has say a chronic low-grade
trauma they're in a relationship and the
relationship is just kind of dismissive
or denigrating they're not valued but
they're putting up with it you know that
predisposes to trauma having more of an
impact there's something called the
multiple hit hypothesis where we have
more uh insults we're more likely for
the next insult to have a
disproportionate impact so be as healthy
as we can I mean part of the reason we
want to be in physical shape is people
want to look good and be healthy now but
we also want to just preventive medicine
right I'm I'm looking ahead to what
could happen in the future and the same
is true about our mental health and this
is why when we talk about a narrative it
doesn't cost any money you don't need
insurance you don't need to be able to
access care to to sit and and think
about or write about your own life your
own life narrative what's in your life
that's not okay and imagine a job you
see people who are in jobs where know
they're not really liked by the people
around them and maybe that's because
they're good and other people don't want
the good person to shine or whatever it
is and they're just kind of putting up
with it note that that's something in
your life that is causing misery and
distress now that predisposes to
problems in the future so to be aware
and to be honest about that instead of
it's easy to shove it under the rug
because like you said it isn't the big
fireworks thing so look at what what it
what are our life narratives from past
to present and what's going on in my
life now what's okay and what isn't
because how many times will a person
tell you everything's okay sure things
are fine
but then you ask okay let's talk about a
little bit more things are not fine
they'll tell you what isn't fine but the
default of things are fine why that
default it's you know partly because if
we don't feel we can really change
anything then we want to just kind of
say it's all okay and if we feel some
guilt and shame about the things that
aren't okay more reason to sweep it
under the rug so that there are a lot of
reasons where we're not honest with
ourselves if you say someone tell me
what's okay and what's not everything's
okay usually that person isn't just
lying to you the question they're lying
to themselves and and it's not because
they like lying to themselves so life
isn't as good it's because there's a
sense of I should be ashamed of that
there's no way I can change that I don't
understand myself well enough I'm afraid
of that and like it just does not have
to be that way and there are routes to
change that aren't rocket science routes
to change which is another message that
I'm bringing it's not like we need the
most sophisticated help sometimes in
extreme circumstances but think about
your life write a life narrative talk to
somebody you care about and trust these
are things we can do for free that can
really make a big difference in our
lives talk to me about again this is not
medical advice please seek your
psychotherapist of choice etc etc but in
your experience what are the modalities
that uh are the biggest movers when it
comes to helping people to sort of make
the unconscious conscious to unpack the
experiences of their lives to stress
test these assumptions and narratives
that they have that may be erroneous and
due to one incident or a number of
incidents that's kind of whitewashed
everything what are the biggest
modalities the most effective ones that
you like I mean there are ways to get to
come at it but most of the ways that
would come at what you were talking
about is an Insight oriented
Psychotherapy and that could be a kind
of psychotherapy psychodynamic
Psychotherapy for example that is very
very interested in the unconscious mind
or it could be Psychotherapy that's not
just focused on the uncons conscious
mind but focused on self- understanding
can you tell me about you now can you
tell me about you growing up how much
can you tell me can you link the two
okay so that can be Insight oriented
Psychotherapy too it doesn't have to go
right for the unconscious mind but it's
some aspect of curiosity about the
person when we just go strategies to
make things better so to speak like
cognitive behavioral strategies can be
they can be very very helpful but we
need to understand understand what what
is underlying first so otherwise we just
go to what else so we're going to
polishing the hood instead of looking
under the hood maybe it's maybe we don't
feel so great about the car and we
really should polish the hood maybe but
maybe if we're not so happy with the car
let's look underneath at the engine so
let's look at where is something coming
from because then we can gain greater
insight and that in and of itself can
make a difference bring the unconscious
to conscious then we have strategies
that can actually help sometimes if
strategy just decrease symptoms without
going to where the problem is that
doesn't necessarily help maybe that
allows the person to tolerate the
abusive situation longer that's not so
good so we want to come I I don't with
rare exceptions I don't understand not
coming at the process through the lens
of insight like let's start there we
might spend a lot of time there or a
little bit of time there so maybe we get
the insight for example that this person
who is depressed is experiencing a
purely biological depr de they're
handling their life quite well they've
had some trauma but they've dealt well
with it they're they have a good job a
good relationship they're meditating
they're taking care of themselves the
the problem is neurobiological oh then
there's a family history where on that
side of the family people get depressed
out of the blue we might rapidly go to
just the
psychopharmacological happens at times
but we haven't just gone there we've
gone there because we've investigated
and decided that that's where to go so
it's just an example even when the
answers are not through the
psychotherapeutic lens we have to have
some insight to decide that and if I
learn that you were never depressed
until a certain thing happened or until
something big didn't happen but you
change maybe from one place to another a
job a relationship and then things
started changing and then you become
depressed well we may still think maybe
is medicine's a good idea or this or
that but we're not going to leave it at
that we're going to go to why that is
different than what you understand about
it or you don't understand we can bring
to to the surface so it's a process that
honors I think people and our stories
and what goes on inside of us and and I
think we deserve that from the systems
that are allegedly taken care of us
you've mentioned a couple of times about
uh writing things down journaling or
something analogous to journaling is
there a process that you're a
particularly big fan of when it comes to
that no not a single process because it
works differently for different people
and some people like like doing that or
if they don't know if they like it can
take to it pretty readily for others it
can be painstaking and it's it's too
much to do now maybe then they could
speak words and then listen to the words
back from them so it's not how it's done
it's that when we when we make words
whether we say them out loud it's kind
of better in some if we say them out
loud or if we write them but when we
make words it's different than things
bouncing around in our minds there are
different systems of error checking that
come online which is why it's kind of a
joke in psychotherapy but it is true
that every now and then someone will
come in and they'll talk the whole time
and then at the end they'll be oh my
gosh thank you you solved all my
problems we didn't say anything right so
so sometimes that happens it happened in
my own therapy a little while ago I said
wait that thing happened I I I actually
solved the problem by talking about them
because in talking about them they
become real in a different way I'm
putting words and the words the
therapist is still relevant because I'm
putting words that are listened to by
another person that I know and trust and
feel safe with and they're going to be
scrutinized by them as well they're
going they're going to be there to to
you need to not just say complete gobleg
you need to not just Trail off in the
middle of sentences there's a a type of
structure that needs to be there as well
right it's a communication structure
right it scrutinized not in a way that
that person's going to fault me but that
person's interested in what I'm saying
and I want to convey it then in this
case what it allows is not that I
conveyed it to the other person it's
that as I conveyed it I understood it
better and it's that that we're going
for if you get that through lhand
journaling and you're like whoa I read
that and I understand myself better do
that if you get it through more sparse
journaling but it's putting together hey
there are these patterns of how I feel
or or what I do and how it links to how
I feel then do that if you kind of can't
do that but you can talk to somebody
trusted do that the idea is to get it
out of just bouncing around in our our
minds because we often don't solve our
problems that way and then we make like
we talked earli about the
self-fulfilling prophecy then we make a
self-fulfilling prophecy I must be dumb
I can't solve my own problems I've been
thinking about it for years like no all
I'm doing over that time is spinning
wheels how about another modality that
makes things different actually brings
different brain centers online and then
I can solve those problems that's the
that can be the tremendous benefit of
writing or talking and again it doesn't
cost anything you don't have to go
anywhere people can do this if they have
what a pen and paper or another human
being they trust so there are ways we
can really help ourselves that we can do
quite readily what should we be paying
attention
to when it comes to the little voice
that sometimes appears in our heads the
things that we take for granted the the
words that are said the the the
presumptions and assumptions when we
encounter a situation uh is there
something I is there a process that you
advise people to go through when it
comes to that repetitive thought that
the sort of uh narrative that we say
yeah well I can say it in two words and
I'll expand a little bit but the two
words are be curious be curious it's
interesting what's going on in our minds
if there's a shadow voice telling you
how bad you are be interested in that
don't be cowed by it don't be frightened
by it be interested in what comes into
our minds because it's that Curiosity
that lets us better understand and it
lets us put it in its place I have this
voice in my head not literally the voice
of like my own shadow voice I kind of
know where it comes from now that I
think about it right it came from that
denigrating person that bad trauma how I
was raised how I was treated because I
was a little bit different and it's
saying things to me do I think they're
true do I believe they're true I mean
give give an opportunity I said well how
about instead of that negative voice
just having the whole playing field it's
in your brain and it's got a megaphone
how about let it have its say but let
the other side have its say too do you
really believe that maybe you do maybe
you don't it's a little bit of Devil's
Advocate but maybe you do maybe you
don't do you believe it or not believe
it if you don't believe it like I'm the
worst person in the world I can't do
anything right okay do you believe that
if you don't well now we want to look at
that for what it is not telling you
anything except that there's something
in your head that's not real or true or
fair and you don't want it there now you
more get conce it as other that's an
otherness how'd that get in my head now
I start seeing it as alien that doesn't
really belong in me now I can start so
putting my foot in the door so to speak
you give me a little bit of room you put
your foot in the door and next time that
person goes I'm stupid and I can't do
anything okay wait wait a
second that just goes on in my head and
it's gone on in my head for a long time
and maybe even I know why it's it's
gotten there that is not what I believe
so now so let's start again can I do
this
thing now it's a different decision Mak
making process oh no one ever likes me I
shouldn't go say hi to that person is
that really true that no one ever likes
youve been taking it for granted for a
long time if there's a life narrative
actually a lot of people like me but I
had a bad relationship outcome and now I
feel like no one likes me if they're a
potential relationship candidate okay we
put things in place and now maybe
instead of that person going away from
the potential romantic partner they say
hello now they start changing things
because they're not making
self-fulfilling prop you know many
people said I can't meet anyone why
can't you meet anyone I never meet
anyone okay then we look they're
avoiding everyone they could meet right
so you have to meet some people in order
to meet some people that's how that has
to go so then we try and prepare the
person because especially in
relationship is kind of the law of large
numbers so there's a lot of rejection
involved so then we think okay if you're
going to go try something we need to
know what the expected outcome is right
if you want to say hello and be nice to
a child that lives next door and that's
gone well in the past that's probably
going to go well if you're going to
approach a potential relationship
partner then be aware it's a law of
large numbers because if it doesn't go
well well we don't want that person to
then feel bad about themselves like yeah
I got to you I got to bring myself I got
to be able to do this a bunch of times
then there going to be some some good
things are going to come of it so so
there are nuances to it but you can kind
of see I think the basic premise of it
is be curious about what's going on in
here so it doesn't control you because
if it is controlling you that's not the
whole you the whole you isn't to be
controlled in some automatic way it's to
bring yourself to bear and think about
things and arrive at conclusions and
decisions Dr Paul Cony ladies and
gentlemen
this dude I'm so impressed with you
Andrew told me to reach out and uh you
are beyond the real deal I love your a
effect I love how sort of caring and and
and sort of gentle you are with this and
insightful I think you're absolutely
fantastic and I I really really
appreciate your work where should people
go that so many people are going to want
to find out more about what you do where
should they go well I'm I'm out there in
in podcast you can find me through just
Googling and and I think they all get
information out there there in in great
ways everyone interviews in a different
way and then I enjoy them all but they
get information so they're more out
there in the podcast realm the book that
I wrote is called trauma the invisible
epidemic and that also can be just
searched and uh and found there's a
website that just has links to some of
the other podcasts and to the book which
is just it's um um uh Dr Dr Paul Conti
so d p Au l n ti.com and that has links
to some of the other places that I've
that I've appeared Dr Cony I really
appreciate you thank you for today
you're welcome thanks so much for having
me if you enjoyed that episode then
press here for a selection of the best
clips from the podcast over the last few
weeks and don't forget to subscribe